[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle agriculture alimentation
écologique et aussi un peu politique
cette semaine nous recevons Isabelle
Valentin c'est vous qui allez passer sur
le grill et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montana
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Isabelle
Valentin bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Isabelle Valentin vous
êtes donc député les républicains de la
Haute-Loire depuis 2017 mais déjà une
fine politique vous réussissez un tour
de force en faisant de Laurent Wauquiez
votre suppléant en 2022 après avoir été
sa suppléante il y a 5 ans vous êtes
également conseillère départemental très
investi dans la vie locale on vous
connaît aussi comme maraîchère du côté
d'Yssingeaux ou avec votre mari vous
produisez et commercialisez des salades
des radis ou des tomates suivant les
saisons fille de boucher charcutier vous
nous avez commandé un plat à base de
viande bien sûr oui bien évidemment avec
un pot-au-feu prof que l'hiver arrive
aussi et en dessert une panna cotta au
coulis de mangue dans le dessous des
plats les coûts de l'énergie mettent
sous tension les agriculteurs reportages
dans le Pas-de-Calais dans les pieds
dans le plat comment lutter efficacement
contre la salmonelle sans des plumer les
éleveurs de volaille réponse à suivant
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
Isabelle Valentin ce n'est pas vous
faire un jour que de dire que votre
suppléant Laurent Wauquiez est plus
connu plus expérimenté que vous en
politique c'est peut-être aussi votre
mentor et je me dis que vous l'avez
peut-être appelé au moment de choisir
votre menu histoire de ne pas commettre
d'un père c'est bien simple vous a dit
Laurent Isabelle 1 tu flattes des
électeurs deux tu fais du storytelling
sur ta personne et voilà le résultat un
pot-au-feu vous avez appliqué les
consignes à la lettre donc de la viande
de bœuf pour envoyer un signal à vos
nombreux éleveurs bovins de la
Haute-Loire et pour le storytelling et
bien je suis fille de boucher biberonner
à la bavette et au paleron et j'assume
ma passion pour la viande et en plus je
suis moi-même maraîchère quoi de plus
normal donc que de vous vendre mes
carottes poireaux navet et autres panais
bien joué et oui le pot-au-feu raconte
votre vie mais Isabelle Valentin vous
avez quand même eu un doute Laurent dans
le contexte tu es sûr que c'est
politiquement correct de choisir de la
viande réponse du maître oui t'inquiète
tu vas raconter que ce sont des morceaux
pas nobles bon marché et que le
pot-au-feu est un plat complet que l'on
déguste une fois par semaine est-ce que
je me trompe Isabelle Valentin
mais oui je m'en doutais
d'ailleurs il vous dirait que j'ai pas
très bon caractère et que quand on dit
de faire quelque chose juste le
contraire
non le pot-au-feu pour moi c'est
un peu mon histoire parce que vous
l'avez très bien dit c'est la viande
pour mes parents les légumes pour mon
mari et puis c'est un plat enfin le
pot-au-feu quand on mange le pot-au-feu
c'est la convivialité exactement c'est
quelque chose qu'on mange entre amis en
famille ça sent un peu l'hiver
effectivement et voilà c'est c'est
surtout cet aspect très convivial il y a
pas de choix politique dans le
pot-au-feu non vraiment c'est un plat
qui est quand même assez bon marché et
par les temps qui courent ça peut ça
peut plaire aux électeurs oui mais vous
savez moi j'entends sans arrêt les
médias qui nous disent manger bien
manger petit coûte cher mais non bien
manger ne coûte pas cher il suffit
d'acheter et de faire de cuisiner un peu
effectivement et vous prenez un chou
braisé chou brisé 2 euros 50 un chou
pour 5 personnes c'est pas cher un
pot-au-feu c'est pas très cher oui mais
la viande c'est quand même cher oui mais
là sur ces morceaux là non si vous
prenez un faux filet oui on va le goûter
peut-être non on va le goûter ensemble
et vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez alors il sera sûrement moins
réussi que le veau j'imagine vous aimez
cuisiner le pot-au-feu j'aime cuisiner
en général en général oui alors trois
choses à savoir sur le pot-au-feuger
pour réussir sur ton portefeu même si
c'est un plat plutôt simple à faire
alors un pour la viande et je suis sûr
qu'ils appellent Valentin ne va pas me
contredire il faut choisir au moins
trois morceaux de nature de texture et
de goût différent un peu grasse comme le
paleron ou la joue un peu moins grasse
comme le tendron et un peu gélatineuse
qui est le cas dans notre assiette si je
me trompe comme le jarret ou la queue de
bœuf deux questions légumes attention je
parle sous le contrôle sous votre
contrôle il y a le trio de base un
carotte navet auquel on peut ajouter
céleri-rave courge panais topinambour
sans oublier la garniture aromatique
percitent un laurier romarin et un
oignon qui est au clou de girofle là je
pense qu'il y a aussi de la peut-être de
la de la patate douce du céleri et du
célèbre et enfin Brigitte pour la
cuisson comptez 2h30 pour la viande et
pour les légumes attention pour ne pas
avoir une purée de légumes vous ajoutez
les légumes dans la marmite en fonte 30
minutes avant la fin de la cuisson c'est
comme ça que vous faites tout à fait
mais ce que vous avez oublié vous avez
oublié ce qui était le plus important
c'est le samouraï sans
osse
effectivement
parce que la semaine dernière on avait à
votre place aymeric Caron qui est vegan
vous vous êtes une amatrice de viande
vous vous mangez beaucoup de viande
depuis toujours non je mange de la
viande parce que j'aime l'avion
et puis et puis moi je défends le bon et
bien manger et je défends la culture
française la France avant tout c'est
quoi c'est le bon et bien manger c'est
un pays d'éleveur aussi c'est ça et puis
c'est un pays agricole je veux dire on a
du vin je veux dire voilà ça fait partie
de notre culture en général en France on
aime se mettre autour d'une table et
bien manger avec des produits qui sont
sains
parce que c'est pas forcément très bon
pour la santé et puis pour le
réchauffement climatique vous vous avez
réduit parce que on le disait votre papa
était bouché charcutier donc j'imagine
que vous en avez quand même mangé pas
mal étant enfant est-ce que vous avez
réduit un petit peu votre consommation
depuis quelques années avec l'âge oui
avec l'âge j'en mange un peu moins mais
j'apprécie la bonne viande je préfère
je pense que c'est en fait avec la
journée un peu moins mais non non
mais il y a pas de choix il y a pas la
base c'est nos steaks parce qu'on peut
pas faire autrement si on veut sauver la
planète et vous vous dites c'est pas
paraît tique alors moi ça veut dire que
j'ai un raisonnement totalement
différent mais totalement opposé moi je
crois nos éleveurs je crois en notre
agriculture c'est la défense de nos
territoires ruraux je ne mangerai pas de
secte de soja et je ne veux pas de steak
de cellules
c'est remplacer la viande c'est en fait
favoriser notre industrie
agroalimentaire et je comprends qu'il y
ait beaucoup de lobbying là dessus parce
qu'il y a des vrais enjeux financiers
mais vous remplacerez jamais un
pot-au-feu et vous remplacerez jamais
nous chez nous on a le saint gras de
l'élevage bovins sur la viande
je suis désolé là on va pas être
d'accord du tout mais moi je défends mon
élevage et je crois pas vraiment au
niveau climatique arrêtons de dire je
crois qu'on a tellement d'autres choses
à faire qu'à parler que à venir à venir
supprimer l'élevage chez nous c'est mais
vous vous dites locales c'est-à-dire de
l'élevage français et pas faire venir de
la viande en France parce qu'on importe
beaucoup de vie aussi notamment dans les
beaucoup trop et oui faisons travailler
notre agriculteur française
aujourd'hui au niveau de l'alimentation
on est plus souverain on importe 40% de
notre alimentation c'est quelque chose
qui est énorme quand on voit les crises
successives qu'on peut avoir je trouve
que sur le projet de loi de finance on a
très peu de mesure qui concernent nos
agriculteurs demain si on perd notre
agriculture il faut bien savoir qu'on
sera plus souverain on aura exactement
le même problème qu'avec les masques
c'est exactement la même chose vous êtes
enfin vous étiez maraîchère parce que là
vous êtes député vous avez du mal à
concilier ces deux activités mais
maraîchère on peut en vivre on peut en
vivre correctement on peut on allait les
moyens de
les agriculteurs ont gagné peu leur vie
et répercutent mal les prix après quand
ils les vendent comment ça se passe
concrètement nous on était maraîchers on
faisait de la vente directe
donc c'est à dire que quand vous faites
de la viande directe vous vous produisez
les quantités que vous vendez parce que
avec le temps vous savez et puis vous
maîtrisez vos prix on avait après on
travaillait après on avait les marchés
où c'était vente on faisait on faisait
les marchés on arrivait à faire 11
marchés par semaine sur des sur des
grosses saisons et puis on avait des GMS
aussi donc c'est quoi des GMS c'est
grand des moyennes surface Intermarché
et Super U d'accord je reviens un peu
sur la viande Brigitte est-ce que vous
êtes contre l'élevage intensif vous
voulez le supprimer ou pas contre
l'élevage intensif est-ce que vous
voulez je suis pas partisan de l'élevé
alors je le supprimerais pas parce que
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France
il faut nourrir tout le monde
vaut mieux faire de l'élevage intensif
et avoir de quoi produire de quoi
assumer notre souveraineté alimentaire
que d'un n'a rien à voir du tout et
d'être dépendant après ce que je trouve
en France c'est que on met énormément de
normes et de contraintes à nos
agriculteurs et on importe des produits
qui ne respectent pas ces règles-là et
pour moi ça c'est un non sens vraiment
vraiment un non sens pensez qu'il
faudrait légiférer davantage justement
pour bien savoir ce qu'on importe oui il
faut non aujourd'hui il faut importer en
fait qu'on il faut il faut qu'on importe
des choses qui correspondent à ce qu'on
demande à notre agriculture après on
nous dit effectivement la viande AOP on
n'a pas ce genre de choses en France
si ça arrive quand même
on en a parlé qui ont fait des progrès
là-dessus quand même sur la traçabilité
des plantes étrangères pour la viande
d'où ça vient on sait pas comment le on
sait pas comment c'est produit on sait
d'où ça vient mais on sait pas comment
c'est produit et on sait que ce qui
vient de nouvelles élans tout ce qui
vient du Brésil d'Argentine il y a quand
même pas mal de vaccins il y a quand
même pas mal d'hormones il y a quand
même pas mal de choses comme ça mais
après on vous les met dans les raviolis
donc du coup ça soit pas alors un petit
Joseph Saint Joseph
pour accompagner ce plat un petit mot
sur sur le saint Joseph c'est un vin de
la vallée du Rhône c'est une AOC vous
c'est vous qui l'avez choisi parce que
c'est près de chez vous c'est entre
l'Ardèche et la loi c'est donc là il est
en rouge c'est de la Syra
majoritairement et on peut rajouter ce
qui est assez drôle sur le saint Joseph
c'est de la Rousseau ou de la Marsane
10% seulement qui est un blanc qu'on
peut mélanger à la Sira qui est rouge
pour atténuer un peu le goût du vin
parce que c'est un vin qui est assez
prononcé avec des des saveurs de de murs
cassis poivre c'est assez épicé c'est ça
tout à fait c'est ce qui vous plaît vous
dans ce vin oui moi j'aime beaucoup le
saint Joseph parce que
je l'aime beaucoup en bouche en fait et
puis et puis voilà moi je défends ma
région et je défends mes produits
régionaux donc voilà le saint Joseph ça
chez nous ça reste une référence aussi
ça aurait pu être un pionnier ça aurait
pu être un vin qui se marie bien avec la
vente parce qu'il a que la puissance
donc ça mais qui passe bien un bon
accord mais 20 là exactement alors on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollables
puisque vous aimez cuisiner vous avez
une partie de votre famille qui est
quand même dans ces métiers de bouche
oui c'est ça donc votre père mon père
mon grand-père était cuisinier mon frère
était très tard voilà donc on va voir si
vous êtes incollable c'est le quiz ouh
là là
alors Sylvie Valentin c'est devenu un
accessoire qui caractérise le chef en
cuisine la toque mais qui a inventé ce
drôle de chapeau à François Vatel qui
était un pâtissier traiteur au service
au service de Fouquet B Marie-Antoine
carême le pâtissier de Talleyrand Paul
Bocuse vous le connaissez parce qu'il
est pas loin de chez vous la star des
fourneaux triplement étoilé pendant 53
ans et enfin Auguste Escoffier surnommé
le roi des cuisiniers et le cuisinier
des rois donc qui a inventé la toque
ça aurait pu être Bocuse parce qu'il en
a une belle et il aime bien la montrer
mais en fait c'est Marie-Antoine Carême
qui était le pâtissier de Talleyrand et
qui était un inventeur parce que c'est
lui aussi qui a inventé la pièce montée
en pâtisserie
[Rires]
on se régale aussi du bouillon qui est
le nom donné à la fin du 19e siècle à
des restaurants plutôt bon marché avec
une décoration Art Nouveau et qui
servait principalement et bien des
bouillons et des bass morceaux de viande
alors comment s'appelait le premier
bouillon parisien et il a été créé en
1860 à le bouillon racine B le bouillon
Julien c'est le bouillon Chartier des le
bouillon Duval
soit non
non
[Rires]
il est encore très connu dans
l'imaginaire il a résisté et en fait non
parce que c'était le nom du boucher
c'est ça qui a perdu
cette bonne idée comme il avait une
petite boucherie c'est dit tiens je vais
faire des petits bouillons avec mon os à
moelle un peu de viande et ça ensuite ça
ça a pris c'est très bon c'est vrai que
vous l'avez pas mis le bouillon mais
normalement oui bien sûr
est-ce que vous vous êtes en bio est-ce
que votre exploitation vous faites très
attention à pas utiliser d'un tronc on
en utilise très peu ce qu'on utilise en
général c'est des matières naturelles
beaucoup de coquilles de choses comme ça
donc après
c'est trop contraignant trop cher
pourquoi parce que ça vous obligerait à
parce qu'après il faut pour avoir la
belle c'est 5000 euros après voilà il y
a tout un tas de moins bons sans doute
les rangs sont moins bons aussi non ah
non non
dans vos on peut avoir sur la tomate le
concombre on peut avoir de la maladie on
peut avoir du puceron sur Thomas et
concombre donc nous on met beaucoup de
coccinelles on met des abeilles aussi
pour polliniser en fait on a des ruches
dans les dans les serres ça ça permet de
traiter naturellement la ruche polinise
donc c'est à dire que vous avez beaucoup
plus de fruits et puis les coccinelles
oui ça tue quand même les pucerons donc
on a les on a tout on a toujours eu les
deux mais depuis des années c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant tout le monde
en parle mais nous ça fait des années
qu'on fonctionne de cette façon et si
vous étiez bio ce serait plus rentable
pour vous pourriez vendre peut-être plus
cher ou oui on vendrait certainement
plus cher mais
après si vous voulez
il y a le respect de la clientèle aussi
enfin moi je me vois pas vendre des
tomates à 5 euros le kilo pour moi c'est
pas éthique voilà parce que ça le vaut
pas la filière bio on en a parlé souvent
dans cette émission on a vu la filière
bio des œufs même maintenant les légumes
ça se casse la figure est-ce que ce
modèle peut encore exister notamment
dans un contexte de baisse de pouvoir de
d'achat de hausse des ça va être une des
difficultés ce sera une des difficultés
et puis on peut avoir une alimentation à
deux vitesses parce que le bio veut rien
dire quand on veut quand je vois moi du
bio d'Espagne ou du bio du Maroc écouter
manger du conventionnel français ça sera
beaucoup mieux et ce sera beaucoup plus
sûr mais il faut quand même éviter les
pesticides non on est d'accord tout à
fait non non mais on est d'accord bien
évidemment et on accompagne pas
suffisamment les les agriculteurs les
maraîchers à passer en bio cette
transition elle est encore compliquée
c'est ce que vous vous
avez pas fait pour des raisons
financières on l'a pas fait parce que
nous on fonctionnait bien comme ça
donc en fait on n'a pas fait mais
une carotte je les ai pas goûtés mais je
suis pas sûr du truc mais une carotte si
vous voulez ça du goût et une carotte
qui a été énormément traitée je suis
désolé à la pas de goût les épinards
c'est pareil je vais dire vous retrouvez
du goût sur l'aiguille parce que parce
qu'il est sain
et que du moment où vous mettez beaucoup
beaucoup de produits de traitement vous
perdez vous en perdez le goût ou alors
énormément d'arrosage si vous voulez
faire pousser très très vite mais
pourquoi aujourd'hui les tomates ne sont
pas bonnes parce qu'en fait elles sont
pleines on nous met que de l'eau elles
ont aucun goût en fait il faut laisser
le temps au temps la culture c'est la
nature
des produits aussi
les gens non plus je veux dire ils
veulent des fraises ou des framboises
ben on va acheter des fraises et des
framboises au mois de décembre
maintenant c'est pas au mois de décembre
et vous trouvez pas que les
comportements commencent à changer
aujourd'hui et que les Français sont
peut-être un peu plus responsables non
non alors ça c'est
il y a ce que les gens disent il y a ce
que les gens font ah d'accord et il y a
une grande marge alors effectivement
quand vous écoutez discutez les gens ils
mangent tous des produits frais et
cuisine tous les jours et puis quand
vous creusez un peu vous vous rendez
compte qu'effectivement il cuisine le
samedi et le dimanche et encore s'il y a
pas je ne quoi faire et que non c'est
pas forcément du produit frais donc le
week-end oui les gens cuisinent un peu
plus quand même nous on voit quand on
fait chou braisé aussi mais c'est pas
facile à faire un chou basé c'est vrai
que c'est pas cher mais ça prend du
temps typiquement vous qui êtes cuisiner
vous avez le temps de cuisiner député
encore aujourd'hui alors beaucoup moins
au grand dame de mon mari de mes enfants
mais beaucoup moins mais si je cuisine
des choses rapides des choses voilà
c'est vrai que
mes enfants et mon mari adorent la
moussaka ça casse c'est très long à
faire
le sac à ouais voilà bon les mots sakans
la moussaka la mousse au chocolat
ouais j'aime bien la cuisine
méditerranéenne tout ce qui est à base
d'aubergines j'adore
mais parce qu'on a des bonnes aubergines
des aubergines qui ont du goût et je ne
mange de l'aubergine que juin juillet
août septembre octobre
la Haute-Loire si vous ne deviez citer
un plat de la Haute-Loire qui la
lentille verte ah oui les lentillesse
très bon pour la santé ça en plus c'est
ça remplace la viande
on peut la faire
avec des petits salés on a un gros souci
sur la lentille puisque oui on a des
problèmes de rendement sur la lentille
donc les produits effectivement ont été
tout ce qui était désherbant tout ça ont
été supprimés et on a un gros souci sur
la lentille alors là avec la sécheresse
il y a vraiment pas de rendement donc il
y a pas de temps
mais regardez la lentille c'est un très
bel exemple en fait vous nous parlez de
la lentille on fait rentrer de la
lentille du Canada oui qui elle est
traitée au glyphosate je sais plus mais
une semaine avant la récolte
je veux dire c'est dramatique mais donc
vous dites bah il y a pas trop de
lentilles cette année parce que là le
rendement est pas bon bah on en mange
pas tant de pays on reporte sur ce qu'il
faudrait faire en fait ce qu'il faudrait
expliquer nous c'est facile pour les
agriculteurs qui produisent de la
lentille c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que c'est voilà pour eux c'est des
pertes
ou céréales et lentilles non
heureusement d'ailleurs ça permet de
carrosser la casse en cas de
d'intempéries ou de sécheresse alors en
France vous savez le repas occupe une
assez large place et c'est souvent
autour d'un bon plat que ce nous les
meilleures histoires que se font la
petite et la grande histoire parfois
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors Isabelle Valentin on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une histoire
autour d'un repas est-ce qu'il y en a
une qui vous est revenu en particulier
il y en a enfin d'histoire autour des
repas mais on a reçu l'année dernière
donc Julien de Normandie qui est venu en
Haute-Loire et contrairement à beaucoup
de nos collègues nous on n'a pas décidé
de l'emmener de l'emmener dans un grand
restaurant mais j'ai voulu qu'il vienne
visiter le self de notre lycée tout
simplement il a mangé au self avec les
élèves les ministres de l'Agriculture
oui on a donc un lycée agricole sur
Yssingeaux avec une filière équine et
puis avec un développement d'ateliers de
transformation sur de la charcuterie sur
du légume et tout et voilà ils ont
trouvé que c'était bien qu'ils puissent
venir là parce que au sein des lycées au
sein des collèges et au sein des écoles
aussi d'ailleurs
on travaille vraiment le local le bon
est bien mangé local et pour que les
enfants
apprennent ce que c'est que le goût
un vrai poulet c'est bête comme
l'eau se détient pas oh je me souviens
plus ce qu'on avait mangé non
franchement je me souviens pas mais bon
mais il avait trouvé ça déjà original
de passer au sel et il nous avait dit
c'est trop bien j'ai l'impression de je
me revois moi-même au lycée il y a pas
si longtemps que ça voilà le temps passe
alors on va parler à présent des œufs
des œufs vont-ils devenir plus rare la
salmonelle détectée dans les
exploitations de volaille oblige à
parfois à abattre tous les levage c'est
le dessous des plats
oui alors que le pouvoir d'achat se
dégrade a bien la consommation des œufs
plutôt bon marché augmente méga au
salmonelles qui peuvent provoquer de
sérieuses intoxications alimentaires les
services vétérinaires sont sur les dents
et le principe de précaution parfois est
lourd à porter pour les éleveurs de
volailles comme l'on constaté Maïté
Frémont et jeanutin
on fait prélèvement comme ça
chiffonnette donc on essuie comme ça on
fait tout le bâtiment ensuite bien sûr à
l'intérieur ce geste Annick est forcé de
le pratiquer tous les trois mois dans
son poulailler 450 ml de poussière
ramassée envoyée directement au
vétérinaire sanitaire un test
bactériologique sur l'environnement de
ces volailles pour détecter si son
cheptel est porteur de la salmonelle on
dort pas on en a fait un la semaine
dernière tant que vous avez pas les
résultats vous avez la boule au ventre
vous dites pourvu que ce soit bon que ce
soit bon parce que si vous appelle que
c'est pas bon vous arrêtez tout il y a
plus un œuf qui part chez vous c'est
terminé depuis 2008 Annick a eu quatre
tests positifs par principe de
précaution elle a dû abattre la totalité
de ces 3000 poules pondeuses activités
peut s'arrêter pendant plusieurs mois et
pendant cet arrêt nous on continue
d'avoir nos charges quoi aimer ça après
etc et souvent ben il faut plus prendre
de salaire quoi parce que il faut
honorer nos charges quoi lors du dernier
prélèvement positif annie a reçu 7000
euros d'aide de l'État alors qu'elle a
perdu 30 000 euros de chiffre d'affaires
bonjour bonjour ça va Chantal ça va
Chantal est-elle aussi éleveuse de
poules depuis un an elle défend la
filière et se bat pour modifier la loi
qu'il n'y ait plus de prélèvement sur
les poussières parce qu'ils font des
prélèvements sur les poussières c'est en
fait c'est l'environnement de la poule
dans l'environnement de leur poulie
retrouve des salmonelles mais en fait la
salmonelle elle vit dans la nature c'est
une bactérie qui est transportée par le
vent les oiseaux les enfin les chats les
sauterelles voilà donc une poule en
plein air nous c'est des poules tout en
plein air bio Label Rouge donc on peut
pas se teste unique sans analyse sur la
poule ou sur l'oeuf et selon elle
injuste mais à l'Agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire le discours
différents il y avait des contre
expertises avant il y en a plus parce
que quand on en trouve on est sûr qu'il
y en a et c'est un coup qui a un vrai
bénéfice en santé publique
les toxines infections notamment avec
Salmonella antéritides qui est qui était
dans les années 90 la principale cause
de Toxie infection chez l'homme elles
ont considérablement régressé grâce à
cette politique d'éradication dans la
filière volaille 250 000 personnes sont
encore atteintes chaque année par la
salmonelle malgré le protocole quel juge
contraignant Annie continue la
production de ses œufs bio et passera le
relais à sa fille
Isabelle Valentin la morale de ce
reportage est implacable le principe de
précaution a permis de faire baisser de
façon drastique ces intoxications et qui
peuvent rendre malades mais qui sont
parfois mortels est-ce que le jeu
finalement n'en vaut pas la chandelle
non parce que on met on met en péril des
exploitations agricoles et c'est un peu
un peu ça rejoint ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure on fait rentrer en France
des œufs qui qui n'ont pas forcément ces
contrôles là non mais vous répondez pas
vraiment à ma question est-ce que
finalement ce principe de précaution qui
consiste à les repérer cette salmonelle
sur des surfaces vitrées ou sur des murs
n'en vaut pas la chandelle puisque le
scientifique nous dit oui mais on a
considérablement la c'est efficace pour
moi non si vous voulez
on peut pas en fait analyser
l'environnement qui est la nature si
vous voulez c'est contraire parce que on
ne veut plus avoir plus de ça le bonheur
on veut plus d'élevage en cage on est
bien d'accord mais on veut quand même
des œufs d'accord et on met notre
élevage je vais c'est un élevage en
plein air donc dans la nature et dans la
nature la personne a très bien dit il y
a forcément de la salmonelle alors que
il y ait des tests sur les œufs et sur
les poules oui qu'on teste
l'environnement donc parce que
l'environnement c'est la nature oui mais
sauf que l'environnement contamine après
les il faut tester
donc on a on a par exemple un test
positif à la salmonelle dans
l'environnement avant tuer tout un
cheptel et de jeter tous les œufs ce
qu'on appelle du gaspillage alimentaire
regardons si à la salmonelle dans l'oeuf
et dans la poule
chaque poulet il faut regarder oui
plutôt que de les abattre donc là on a
bête
conception du principe de précaution ce
parapluie très large vous paraît
démesuré il faudrait qu'on le réduise et
je pense qu'en France on a tendance à
ouvrir un parapluie puis depuis trois
puis quatre parce que on sait jamais
alors c'est pas l'Europe qui règle aussi
qui régissent la France mais c'est quand
même l'air
parce que on n'a pas aussi tout le tout
le problème de l'agriculture
qui sont fortement touchés sur ma
circonscription et c'est des gens qui
sont à la limite du suicide quand même
parce que contrôle le principe de
précaution d'une demande je ne suis pas
du tout contre le principe de précaution
mais je pense qu'il faut que le principe
de précaution soit appliquée de façon
rationnelle et que si on cherche la
salmonelle dans un œuf et ben on regarde
la chaîne monnaie dans l'oeuf et pas
dans l'environnement donc là il faut
faire évoluer la réglementation pour
vous il faut au moins faire deux ou
trois tests comment est-ce que vous
justifiez oui avant il y avait deux
on la supprime c'est l'Europe qui a
supprimé mais on est en train de
retravailler dessus pour essayer de le
faire de le faire amener mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut tuer je veux dire
autant de bêtes et jeter autant d’œufs
aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui
le premier test ah oui oui moi c'est sur
les exploitations il avait l'air de dire
que à partir du moment où vous vous avez
des contre-exemples qui oui quand ils
refont généralement un deuxième test
souvent le deuxième test est pas négatif
donc il en faudrait trois pour vous au
moins au moins 2 si on a un pour un
compte qu'est-ce qu'on fait on en fait
un 3e
ça éviterait d'abattre toute mais on
abat enfin faut voir le nombre de poules
qu'on est qu'on est en train d'abattre
donc aujourd'hui il faut savoir que sur
les toutes petites poules il y a on a
pratiquement plus de petites poules en
France ils peuvent pas racheter en fait
un nouveau cheptel parce que il y a
pratiquement plus petite poule ou pas en
France et l'État devrait mieux
indemniser aussi parce que là
pourquoi l'État l'État peut pas toujours
tout donner je veux dire en général ils
travaillent pour des grandes filières
puisque
ils travaillent alors je sais pas je
veux pas donner des noms mais il
travaille pour certaines grandes
entreprises je crois que c'est assez
grandes entreprises de prendre des
assurances ou de rembourser en fait le
l'agriculteur parce que l'agriculteur
invest dans ces bâtiments
la grande entreprise va lui demander
d'acheter tel engrais pas talent tel
aliment enfin tout est très codé et et
et après voilà lorsqu'il y a sale
menelle
on en a déjà parlé ici oui il y a aucun
accompagnement après un des gros soucis
aussi c'est que les gens qui font la
collecte des œufs normalement devrait en
fait désinfecter les camions chaque fois
qu'ils arrivent dans une exploitation or
ils le font pas c'est à dire qu'ils
arrivent chez Pierre hop il suffit qu'il
y a la salmonelle ils vont chez Paul hop
ils dépose la salle monnaie et ils vont
chez je ne sais qui donc effectivement
il y a un gros travail à faire là dessus
sur la désinfection des camions de
collecte je sais pas si c'est lorsqu'il
était au self mais je sais que vous avez
alerté
ministre et qu'est-ce que vous lui avez
demandé concrètement parce que vous avez
beaucoup d'éleveurs de poules qui
lancent des SOS même dans votre
département oui oui tout à fait et ben
on lui a l'air on l'a alerté sur sur
cette difficulté là et n'oubliez pas
demandé quelque chose de plus concret
d'essayer de se
après après c'est un problème beaucoup
plus profond bon ce qui est ce qui est
sur l'Europe on est en train d'y
travailler enfin moi j'avais alerté
Agnès c'est vrai mais et François-Xavier
Bellami là-dessus donc ils sont en train
de voir ce qu'il faut faire et puis et
puis il y a un vrai souci après avec ses
grandes entreprises en fait de de
producteur d'eux qui sous-traitent
finalement chez nos agriculteurs ou eux
doivent aussi prendre la responsabilité
mais c'est un problème financier et vous
allez essayer de convaincre aujourd'hui
Marc féno oui tout à fait oui tout à
fait il a des courriers qui sont partis
peut-être sur cette question là et
vous-même vous pourriez déposer des
amendements éventuellement s'il y a une
longue parce que non on peut rien faire
nous nous en tant que tel après non on
peut pas faire grand chose au niveau
législatif on peut pas faire grandir non
et quand vous dites les grandes boîtes
doivent prendre leur responsabilités
c'est-à-dire payer une partie des
indemnités aux petits éventuellement
peut-être
rembourser les les prêts qu'ils ont sur
les bâtiments en attendant de retrouver
une trésorerie il y a peut-être des
choses comme ça ce que c'est quand même
assez facile vous arrivez moi je vais
arriver je vais vous dire vous allez me
produire tant d'œuf hop mais par contre
vous investissez dans vos magasins dans
vos dans vos bâtiments et puis attention
vous n'achèterez l'aliment chez moi
parce que parce que c'est moi qui vous
vends l'aliment en fait l'agriculteur il
a pas de marge de manœuvre et je crois
qu'il faut arrêter ça les agriculteurs
je vais dire souvent ils sont je le mets
en guillemets bien entendu mais peu
considérer parce qu'ils ont un
agriculteur aujourd'hui c'est un chef
d'entreprise sont dans les mains de
l'agroalimentation
pas de marge de manœuvre alors non très
peu qui fixe à 15000 euros le plafond
des indemnités elle elle a reçu 7000
euros mais en fait le plafond parce que
je crois que c'est poulet était un peu
vieille donc si on prendra
et c'est 15000 euros mais peut-être
qu'il faudrait relever ce plafond c'est
quelque chose que vous ayez de vous
battez pour ça moi là je me bats surtout
c'est déjà pour que les gens qui font la
collecte désinfectent les camions parce
qu'en fait la salmonelle on la
transporte d'une exploitation à l'autre
ça paraît un problème d'hygiène et du
coup ça stigmatise beaucoup l'éleveur
c'est la faute de l'éleveur s'il y a de
la salmonelle alors ça peut être la
faute de l'éleveur en général c'est pas
la faute de l'éleveur puisque la seule
manel elle est dans la nature nous la
très bien dit on a de la salmonelle
en tout cas aujourd'hui les œufs c'est
vrai on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
des protéines qui sont pas très cher
moins cher parfois que des bonnes pièces
de viande ça veut dire que si on n'a pas
beaucoup de cheptel comme ça ça va
renchérir le prix des œufs on manque
aujourd'hui là actuellement au moment
la demande est en fortement est très
forte et l'offre et du coup moins
l'offre est beaucoup moins importante
puisque si chaque fois chaque fois vous
tuez des cheptels voilà oui mais en même
temps s'il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens mangent d'eux et s'il y a pas des
contrôles stricts mais il y a encore le
risque que des gens soient intoxiqués il
faut du contrôle mais si vous voulez il
faut pas que du contrôle quand on
contrôle après bah faut aussi aider les
exploitants si on veut garder nos
filières il faut aussi aider les
exploitants
et aujourd'hui je trouve qu'ils sont pas
suffisamment en compagnie
on va parler à présent d'un autre sujet
qui touche cette fois les maraîchers les
agriculteurs c'est le prix de l'énergie
qui s'envole aujourd'hui les coûts
explosent et beaucoup ne parviennent pas
à répercuter cette augmentation sur les
prix de vente on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
[Musique]
et oui les agriculteurs sont menacés par
la flambée des prix de l'électricité
leur facture flambe or certains sont
très énergivores comme se cultivateur
d'endives du Pas-de-Calais qui pourrait
mettre la clé sous la porte reportage
Clément Perrot
[Musique]
Daniel Bouquillon est un maraîcher en
sursis au 1er janvier 2023 il doit
renouveler son contrat d'électricité des
tarifs qu'il obtiendra dépendra la
survie de son exploitation son activité
est particulièrement gourmande en
électricité il cultive des endives ces
racines ont été arrachés aujourd'hui
donc on voit les conserver une
température dans entre 0 et - 2 degrés
cette phase de conservation peut durer
jusqu'à un an elle se fait dans cette
chambre froide qui consomme en
permanence une électricité importante
c'est le poste le plus énergivore au
niveau de la production par exemple là
nos racines sont à 0,5 degrés tout ça 24
sur 24 on ne peut pas se permettre une
rupture de froid sinon on va dégrader
les racines et les racines nous donnera
pas un beau produit les racines germent
ensuite dans cette pièce plongée dans le
noir voilà des endives
prête à être récolté là encore la
température doit absolument être régulée
aussi bien l'eau
que l'air là vous avez une eau qui est
relativement fraîche de l'ordre de 15
degrés si on les sait faire la nature
tout seul on arriverait pas avoir un
beau produit est-ce que consommateur
achetant avec les yeux on n'a pas
d'autre solution
entreprise de Daniel négocie ses tarifs
d'électricité chaque année ou tous les
trois ans son opérateur est EDF et en
deux ans les prix se sont envolés en
2021 il payait son kilowatt-heure moins
de 6 centimes pour l'année prochaine EDF
lui propose un contrat à plus de 52
centimes c'est près de 9 fois plus
le poste de dépenses passerait alors de
9600 euros en 2021 après de 80000 euros
pour 2023 une somme considérable pour
une petite entreprise de 8 salariés
Daniel et son fils Mathieu qui reprend
l'exploitation ont beau tourner et
retourner les chiffres il ne voit pas
comment composer avec les nouveaux prix
proposés
pas des prix comme ça c'est sûr
une augmentation des coûts d'énergie une
augmentation des intrants là franchement
je vois pas trop de solutions décemment
on peut pas porter sur le dos du
consommateur une telle augmentation le
consommateur a lui aussi ses problèmes
des représentants de la filière ont été
reçues au ministère de l'Agriculture les
maraîchers espèrent une aide du
gouvernement pour limiter la flambée des
prix de l'électricité dans les hauts de
France principal régions productrices
d'endives se sont 4000 emplois qui sont
concernés
alors on le voit Isabelle Valentin dans
ce reportage ce maraîcher ne reçoit
aucune aide il y a un trou dans la
raquette pour les agriculteurs pour les
éleveurs pour les maraîchers oui oui il
y a un trou dans la raquette mais le
problème de l'énergie est un problème
beaucoup plus profond en fait on a on a
tué notre filière du nucléaire si on
avait gardé notre filière du nucléaire
aujourd'hui on serait alors je le mets
en guillemets les rois du pétrole on
avait tout ce qu'il fallait quand même
on avait vraiment tout ce qu'il fallait
il y a eu du lobbying anti-nucléaire
comme on a de la grippe comme on a de la
grippe plastique on a mal entretenu la
filière ou on a ce qu'on fait ce name a
fermé mais on n'a pas entretenu la
filière aujourd'hui le souci majeur
c'est que on a plus de personnes formées
pour entretenir nos réacteurs c'est pour
ça que en fait on prend on prend
beaucoup de retard c'est pour ça que
vous avez lancé une commission d'enquête
d'ailleurs sur la filière nucléaire
on a un groupe énergie mais voilà le
problème est profond et grave et c'est
pas cette année c'est l'année prochaine
et encore l'année d'après on a 56
réacteurs quelque chose comme ça on en a
26 qui fonctionne sur ces 26 on en a la
moitié qui doivent passer les garanties
décennales alors on dit OUI plan de
sobriété on fait moins consommer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire à ce maraîcher
de Me consommer pour ces endives le sa
production qui s'arrête oui et le je
pense que le gouvernement ne mesure pas
en fait ce qu'il est en train de se
passer en France on est en train de
désindustrialiser la France et on est en
train de tuer notre agriculture par la
même occasion on a là ce producteur
d'endives on a exactement le même souci
sur tous les gens les agriculteurs les
séries ce qu'ils font aux tomates
concombres courgettes qui touche tous
les pays européens il y a pas que la
France qui est bien ça et qui en France
on avait tout ce qui nous fallait
renversé mais
on construit aussi plus de réacteurs
nucléaires ça a été annoncé ça prend du
temps forcément mais ça va prendre du
temps le premier réacteur je crois que
c'est 2035 en fonctionnement alors en
attendant il y a des il y a des
alternatives et notamment chez les
agriculteurs on peut faire de la
méthanisation il y a aussi
l'agrivoltaïsme vous y croyez vous ça
peut alors on peut être autosuffisant
sur sa ferme sur son exploitation si
vous voulez
un agriculteur et les terres agricoles
pour moi
c'est fait pour nourrir la population
c'est pas fait pour on va pas produire
des céréales pour pour faire de
l'énergie parce qu'on manquera après
d'alimentation tout simplement le rôle
d'un agriculteur son rôle premier c'est
de nourrir quand même les populations et
les terres agricoles sortent à ça on
voit aujourd'hui
sur la filière photovoltaïque notamment
l'éolien aussi
des gens qui viennent racheter des
terres agricoles pour implanter du
photovoltaïque et pour remplacer demain
attention on manquera dedans
réalimentaire de terre agricole et donc
évidemment alors je comprends moi
l'agriculteur et c'est absolument pas
une critique votre votre hectare vaut
3000 euros on va vous donner 25 000
c'est rentable disons que quand vous
arrivez pas à joindre les deux bouts et
que ça fait déjà des années des années
que vous y arrivez pas oui
de la possibilité de mettre des petites
unités
de méthanisation qui font fonctionner
l'exploitation mais mettre des grosses
unités de méthanisation et mettre des
champs de photovoltaïques comme c'est le
cas actuellement moi je suis totalement
contre parce que dans 10 ans ça sera
comme le nucléaire on nous dira ah ben
on a plus de terres agricole dites mais
on peut plus produire et vous n'avez
c'est un vrai danger exactement répondu
à la question de Brigitte parce que que
fait ce notre cultivateur notre
maraîcher là qui fait ses endives est-ce
qu'il faut lui faire un bouclier
tarifaire ce qu'il faut le subventionner
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'il
est en train de mettre la clé sous la
porte il faut il faudrait parce que le
nucléaire on va pas attendre l'ouverture
il faudrait subventionner beaucoup de
monde parce que moi j'ai l'industrie de
la plasturgie chez moi
j'ai déjà
50 licenciements qui sont annoncés donc
une petite entreprise de 30 une de 10
tout simplement parce que on leur
multiplie par 9 le coup de l'énergie et
que au niveau rentabilité c'est pas
possible plus grave j'ai un sieur Le Jo
qui m'a appelé en me disant moi je vais
fermer sa belle parce que là tout de
suite
le coût de l'énergie avec mon le nouveau
contrat qu'on propose représente 50% de
mon chiffre d'affaires
mais s'il ferme une toutes nos
chaudières bois parce qu'on a des gros
réseaux de chaleur
plus de silure plus de petits pellets
plus rien et d'ailleurs donc voilà aussi
pour tous ceux qui ont acheté des
chaudières à bois c'est plus compliqué
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué donc en
fait le mal est profond un appel au
gouvernement disant il faut des aides là
d'urgence c'est voilà c'est tout mais il
faut des ex pour tout le monde et quand
on quand on sait qu'on a 3300 milliards
de dettes ça va être compliqué quand
même parce qu'on n'a pas fait des
économies pendant 10 ans et aujourd'hui
où on a une vraie crise il va falloir
encore mettre beaucoup d'argent est-ce
que c'est la faute de Bruxelles on
entend ça parfois il faut sortir du
marché d'électricité parce que comme le
gaz augmente notamment alors la guerre
en Ukraine que les les prix sont indexés
je suis désolé c'est la faute à
nous-mêmes puisque nous on avait tout ce
qui nous fallait on n'a pas su
l'entretenir donc c'est facile de dire
après c'est la faute à Bruxelles non il
fallait entretenir ce qu'on avait il
fallait le développer donc on peut ne
s'en prendre voilà la France s'en prend
à elle-même et en tant que ménagère
puisque vous nous dites que vous faites
la cuisine on commence à le sentir dans
les étals de supermarché il y a de moins
en moins de produits sans doute moins
d'endives parce que des maraîchers
mettent laqués sous la porte mais par
exemple dans la biscuiterie et dans
l'agroalimentaire aussi des yaourts et
des produits lactés des des producteurs
ne peuvent plus payer certains produits
par exemple des biscuits ceux qui sont
trop énergivores on les laisse tomber
est-ce que vous êtes inquiète de voir
aux états de supermarché se réduire
comme pour chagrin je vais très peu
supermarché je suis désolé
je fais mes courses au marché chez mes
producteurs non mais pour y avoir des
pénuries peut-être mais on a alors on a
des pénuries sur le lait on a des
pénuries on a des pénuries sur la farine
on a nos verreries qui vont arrêter
parce que ça coûte très cher pour dire
du vert c'est à dire que
[Musique]
les pots de yaourt en verre tout ça on
va avoir enfin je veux dire c'est
vraiment global en fait ça veut dire tu
as un problème global plan sociaux à
venir vous nous déjà dans votre la
transcription on avait certains qui
étaient annoncés moi je pense que enfin
je j'espère vraiment me tromper mais
mais je pense que notre industrie va pas
tenir le coup donc vous êtes très
inquiète là en fait oui je suis hyper
inquiète oui oui je suis père inquiète
je rencontre moi les chefs d'entreprise
très régulièrement
la mécanique générale c'est pareil c'est
énergivore les vertiges je vous l'ai dit
la plasturgie ferme des lignes de
production alors le plastique est très
décrié c'est vrai n'empêche qu'en terme
de
garantie sanitaire un steak haché
congelé si vous le mettez pas dans du
plastique je sais pas comment vous le
conservez voilà donc oui
les prix sur les prix de vente alors
peut-être pas toute la hausse des prix
d'énergie c'est impossible est-ce que
vous pensez que dans la filière tout le
monde joue le jeu aussi on voit qu'elle
est il y a eu des renégociations
commerciales il y a l'intermédiaire il y
a le distributeur là vous trouvez que
certains jouent le jeu tous ou pas du
tout non je pense qu'il il y a beaucoup
de spéculation
on a beaucoup de spéculation à tout
niveau
on a eu de la spéculation
l'an dernier déjà sur tout ce qui était
bâtiment
la laine de verre
les plaques de
en plâtre je veux dire on a eu beaucoup
de spéculations là-dessus et on a encore
de la spéculation notamment sur les
granules de bois donc il y a des gens
qui sont enrichissent sur le dos sur la
crise sur la mais ça va pas durer et ils
ont tort de faire ça parce que parce
qu'en fait on est en train de tuer notre
économie mais c'est pas le cas des
maraîchers par exemple
les maraîchers je veux dire c'est très
compliqué pour tous ceux qui font du
légume d'hiver ça va être très compliqué
parce que vous allez pas vous allez pas
chauffer une serre pour faire de la
salade parce que vous allez pas vendre
enfin les salades aujourd'hui sont quand
même à 1,70 le prix moyen d'une salade à
cette époque c'est 70 cm
typiquement vous aviez des serres et
donc vous pour vous les coûts de
l'énergie
explosent aussi oui mais nous alors
cette année
sinon effectivement c'est exactement la
même chose vous avez arrêté parce que
c'est
déjà deux trois ans qu'on en parlait
mais tout le monde est touché mais tout
le monde est touché alors on va passer
au dessert à présent dans cette émission
et c'est le péché mignon
avec le dessert de d'Isabelle Valentin
une panacotta littéralement crème cuite
à base de crème de lait de sucre et de
gélatine c'est un totem des desserts
italiens populaires dans toute l'Italie
originaire visiblement du Piémont la
petite histoire attention souvent c'est
les histoires un peu ils tiennent pas
vraiment la route dit que la plus
ancienne panna cotta serait née au
sud-est de Turin au début du XIXe siècle
c'est une femme d'origine hongroise qui
aurait élaboré ce dessert avec un
excédent de lait vous voyez à l'époque
il y a pas de pénurie en Italie il est
souvent dégusté avec un coulis de fruits
rouges mais vous vous avez opté pour un
coulis de mangue alors je dis bien
attention à coulis de manque pas des
mangues fraîches parce qu'on aurait crié
à la trace carbone mais le coulis
mais il a bien fallu les importer me dis
toi à l'oreille donc
Isabelle Valentin c'est vrai que
j'aurais pu prendre des fruits rouges
puisqu'on est aussi producteur de fruits
rouges c'est votre fils qui fait des
framboises hein c'est ça non nous on
faisait on faisait on maraîchage on
faisait aussi on faisait aux fruits
aussi quelques fruits rouges fraises et
framboises et mes enfants sont
liquoristes et donc ils ont ils ont des
plantations de framboises de fraises
puis après c'est plus très typique chez
nous puisque c'est de la verveine et
puis la menthe et voilà et alors la
mangue c'est juste un goût vous aimez
beaucoup j'adore vraiment j'adore la
mangue et vous vous en achetez quand
même malgré le bicarbonate dont on
parlait c'est pas bien mais oui j'achète
des mangues
le fruit rouge
on a le groupement on a les perles
rouges du volley nous donc c'est un
groupement de producteurs qui mais un
très gros groupement de producteurs donc
qui font fraises framboises groseilles
tout ce qui est fruits rouges et qui
sont vraiment exceptionnels alors quelle
est la clé d'une bonne panna cotta pour
Isabelle Valentin
un petit peu de vanille
exactement voilà très bien vous savez la
faire la panna cotta j'en fais pas
souvent franchement j'en fais pas
souvent j'en prends quand je suis dans
les dans les restaurants
alors je pense aussi que ça vient alors
ma grand-mère est originaire des
Hautes-Alpes et ma grand-mère
habite-t-il un petit village au-dessus
de Saint Véran
sur qui était à 10 km de la frontière
italienne l'autre commune d'Europe
s'interroge donc nous on était dans un
petit village au dessus parce que le
village est à 2500 mètres d'altitude et
et voilà et la Panach peut-être
et j'aime beaucoup la cuisine italienne
effectivement
et vous allez nous dire si elle est
bonne
vous Jean-Pierre vous êtes un fan de
panna cotta aussi
quand elle est trop dure on peut planter
notre cuillère comme ça et qu'elle reste
comme dans un bout de ciment
vous mettez quel gélatine quand vous la
faites mais vous la faites jamais en
fait voilà et vous moi je mets de la
gélatine voilà
un peu plus naturel et puis mais un peu
plus difficile à doser puis on peut
aussi mettre de la gomme arabique mais
voilà ça se sont trois gélifiants
différents les gélifiants le plus
courant et effectivement le gélifiant
animal je l'ai de boeuf où je l'ai de
porc mais AGA c'est pas mal et là j'ai
la team elle est très bonne et merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LC